oh  well these sneakers look I gave through  these sneakers a year ago these they  look like she warm a year I mean you  definitely been knighted in the Bronx  thank you for literally making me the  coolest person it's a fly and they match  I'm gonna do  oh  man oh  she got little feet too huh I'm not  gonna lick the bottom of those sneakers  love this one I love this one I love it  more I love a woman that wears a big  watch do bearing more so iconic that you  know I passed the Barrymore theater and  think she owns it what is it velvet you  know she just she flows with it I mean  I'm the same way today I look like Saint  Patty's Day but you know somebody gotta  Rock the Boat tiger I should get down to  the stage pizza I'll see you later